>>> WE WANT TO CONTINUE OUR
COVID COVERAGE BY SHOWING YOU
WHAT A COVID PATIENT STRUGGLING
TO BREATHE LOOKS LIKE.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS TO PEOPLE
WHEN EVERY WEAPON IN OUR ARSENAL
IS NOT USED TO ITS FULLEST
POTENTIAL OR EVEN THE MOST
OBVIOUS ONE, THE VACCINE.
WE WARN YOU, THIS MAY BE
DISTURBING TO SOME BUT IT IS
NECESSARY TO SEE UP CLOSE JUST
WHAT THIS NATION IS FIGHTING
PATIENT BY PATIENT.
RANDI KAYE HAS THE STORY.
>> Reporter: YOU ARE WATCHING
THE DESPERATE ATTEMPT TO SAVE A
COVID PATIENT'S LIFE.
THIS 75-YEAR-OLD WOMAN IS HAVING
SERIOUS TROUBLE BREATHING AND IS
IN DESPERATE NEED OF OXYGEN.
>> SO THIS PATIENT WAS BEING
MAINTAINED ON NONINVASIVE
VENTILATION AND UNFORTUNATELY
FAILED AND SO WE HAD TO
TRANSITION TO MECHANICAL
VENTILATION WHICH REQUIRES
PLACEMENT OF AN AIRWAY WITHIN
THE TRACHEA, THE WIND PIPE SO
THE PATIENT HAS TO BE SEDATED TO
ALLOW US TO ACCESS THE AIRWAY.
>> Reporter: THIS DOCTOR IS A
PULMONOLIGIST AND MEDICAL
DIRECTOR AT ST. ANTHONY'S
FLORIDA IN ST. PETERSBURG,
FLORIDA.
AS THE PATIENT'S OXYGEN LEVELS
DROPPED DOCTORS QUICKLY PREPARED
TO INTUBATE HER SO THEY COULD
GET HER ON A VENTILATOR TO HELP
HER BREATHE.
THE PROCESS INVOLVES A SLENDER,
SURGICAL PROBE.
>> HE HAS A STYLETTE THAT GOES
IN THE TUBE TO MAINTAIN RIGIDITY
SO HE CAN GUIDE WHERE THE TUBE
GOES AND USES A BLADE TO LIFT
THE TONGUE OUT OF THE WAY SO HE
CAN VISUALIZE IT.
IT IS A FIBER OPTIC
VISUALIZATION.
THERE IS A LITTLE CAMERA SO HE
CAN VISUALIZE THE AIRWAY AND
GUIDE THE TUBE INTO PLACE.
>> Reporter: IT HAS TO BE
PRECISE YET TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE.
LIVES ARE ON THE LINE.
>> YOU GOT IT.
>> YOU'RE IN THERE.
>> SHE IS COMING BACK.
>> HER HEART RATE IS STABLE.
>> Reporter: FOR THIS PATIENT A
SECOND CHANCE.
LATER WE LEARNED SHE HAD
RECEIVED HER FIRST DOSE OF THE
VACCINE BUT GOT COVID WHILE
WAITING FOR HER SECOND SHOT.
STILL, MOST PATIENTS HERE ARE
UNVACCINATED.
ACROSS THE BAY CARE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM INCLUDING ST. ANTHONY'S
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE INCREASED
TENFOLD SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
JULY AND ABOUT #85% OF THE ICU
PATIENTS ARE UNVACCINATED.
DO THEY EXPRESS REGRET THEY ARE
NOT VACCINATED?
>> WE HAVE HAD PATIENTS THAT
COME AND REQUEST, CAN I GET A
VACCINE NOW?
BUT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS MEANT TO
BE PREVENTATIVE AND ONCE YOU
HAVE THE DISEASE IT IS NOT
HELPFUL.
>> Reporter: DR. WARREN ABEL A
CRITICAL CARE PHYSICIAN IN ICU
CALLS THE PANDEMIC, QUOTE, OUR
WORLD WAR II.
UNVACCINATED PATIENTS AS YOUNG
AS 20 YEARS OLD DYING BEFORE HIS
EYES.
>> EVERY PERSON THAT PASSES AWAY
THAT WAS UNVACCINATED, IT IS A
PREVENTIBLE DEATH.
IT IS VERY -- IT'S HEART
BREAKING ACTUALLY.
>> Reporter: 27 OF THE 28 ICU
BEDS HERE ARE FILLED WITH COVID
PATIENTS.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: FAR TOO MANY ARE ON
VENTILATORS LIKE THIS WOMAN.
>> CAN YOU NOD YOUR HEAD FOR ME?
THERE YOU ARE.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD.
>> ALMOST ALWAYS BEFORE THEY GET
INTUBATED THEY WANT TO CALL
THEIR LOVED ONES TO TELL THEM
THEY LOVE THEM AND SAY GOOD-BYE.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, OFTENTIMES
THAT IS THE LAST TIME THEY SPEAK
TO THEM.
>> Reporter: FOR PEOPLE WHO SAY
THIS IS FLORIDA, WE'RE PAST IT
IN FLORIDA.
WE'RE GOOD.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE WORST
WAVES I'VE EXPERIENCED.
I MEAN, THINGS ARE AS BAD WITH
COVID AS THEY'VE EVER BEEN IN
FLORIDA.
>> COME SPEND A DAY WITH ME.
YOU'LL SEE WE'RE NOT OKAY.
I WALK DOWN THE HALL AND ALMOST
ALL OF OUR PATIENTS ARE ON THEIR
BELLIES TO HELP THEM BREATHE.
>> Reporter: RANDI KAYE JOINS US
NOW.
GIVEN THE SURGE IN PATIENTS,
GIVEN THAT WE'RE NOT OKAY AS
THESE HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE
SAYING, DOES THE HOSPITAL HAVE
WHAT IT NEEDS?
DOES IT HAVE ENOUGH VENTILATORS?
>> Reporter: WELL, JOHN, THEY
HAVE DIPPED INTO THEIR HURRICANE
SUPPLY OF VENTILATORS WHICH THEY
WOULD HAVE PUT ASIDE FOR A MAJOR
STORM SO THEY ARE USING THOSE
AND ALSO THESE REFRIGERATED
MOBILE UNITS AS MORGUES SO THEY
NEED THOSE AS WELL.
FUNERAL HOMES ALSO, JOHN, IN
THIS AREA ARE FEELING THE
IMPACT.
WE SPOKE TO THE FUNERAL DIRECTOR
AT WILSON FUNERAL HOME HERE IN
TAMPA AND HE TOLD ME NOT ONLY
HAS HE BURIED FRIENDS OF HIS BUT
HE'S ALSO RUNNING OUT OF CASKETS
AND IS NOW ORDERING MULTIPLE
CASKETS A DAY.
HE HAD TO MOVE THE HEARSES OUT
OF THE GARAGE TO MAKE ROOM FOR
MORE CASKETS INSIDE THE FUNERAL
HOME.
HE ALSO TOLD ME HE IS HAVING
TROUBLE SCHEDULING FUNERALS
BECAUSE THE CEMETERIES ARE SO
BUSY HE CAN'T EVEN GET A FUNERAL
SCHEDULED ON THE BOOKS.
SO I WILL JUST TELL YOU THAT
BEING IN THAT ICU FOR ANYONE WHO
THINKS THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
WEARING MASKS OR WE MIGHT NOT
NEED TO GET A VACCINE, THEY
SHOULD SPEND A DAY WITH THOSE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WALKING IN
THAT ICU, WALKING IN THEIR
SHOES.
IT COULD CHANGE A MIND, JO